el jefe del pentágono y secretario de
defensa de eeuu el general lloyd austin
visitó este domingo israel es la primera
visita oficial de un alto cargo
estadounidense lo hizo con un mensaje de
compromiso hacia el que su principal
aliado en medio oriente
durante nuestra reunión le reafirme al
ministro gans que nuestro compromiso con
israel es duradero y firme me he
comprometido a continuar con nuestra
relación estrecha y he querido
garantizar que israel va a mantener su
ventaja cualitativa militar así como
fortalecer su seguridad
juntos strange news raw secure austin se
reunión con el ministro de defensa en
funciones benny ganz los políticos
dieron una rueda de prensa conjunta en
israel existe preocupación por el
acercamiento de eeuu a irán su principal
enemigo para recuperar el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 abandonado por donald
trump en 2018 israel se opone por el
temor de que irán pueda desarrollar
armas nucleares a largo plazo para la
defensa de este criterio austin
y enfatiza el secretario agustín que
israel ve a estados unidos como un socio
pleno en todas las amenazas
operacionales
cabe destacar iran el teherán de hoy
posee una amenaza estratégica para la
seguridad internacional en todo el medio
oriente y para el estado de israel su
red
y la política exterior de la
administración de job aiden está virando
israel e irán se están acusando de
sabotajes y ataques en siria además eeuu
recuperó la ayuda de cooperación con
palestina son gestos que no han gustado
en ciertos sectores conservadores de
israel provocando que yo y austin haya
tenido que enviar un mensaje de
tranquilidad